llegó la hora de la información
económica en france 24 por ello me
acompaña aquí en el estudio mi compañero
luís mentes louis buenas noches
bienvenidos iniciamos en mexico porque
datos oficiales revelan un aumento del
desempleo así es de valentina de acuerdo
con los resultados de la encuesta
nacional de ocupación y empleo la
desocupación subió alrededor de un punto
porcentual durante el primer trimestre
del presente año en comparación con el
mismo período del año 2020 en el período
enero-marzo de 2021 la población ocupada
fue de 53 millones de personas cifra
inferior en 2.1 millones si la
comparamos con la del primer trimestre
del año 2020 los datos revelan una
recuperación lenta del país que debido a
la pandemia presentó una caída económica
por el orden del 8.2 por ciento el año
pasado después noticia bastante negativa
y otra que también es la que golpea la
bolsa chilena un día después de las
elecciones para la constituyente y es
que el índice de precios selectivo de
acciones ipsa cerró con una caída de más
de 9 puntos porcentuales un día después
de que el país
celebrará el proceso comicial de acuerdo
con medios como el mercurio el desplome
sería el peor dentro de la principal
bolsa chilena desde el mes de marzo del
año 2020 cuando la nación decretó un
estado de emergencia por los contagios
de kobe 19 en total la jornada cerró con
una caída de nueve puntos 33 por ciento
y con 4.147 enteros por otro lado se
incrementó en 2% del valor del dólar es
decir 16.4 pesos para cerrar con una
cotización de 716 8 pesos por dólar
también el credit default swap textil de
un instrumento financiero que mide el
riesgo de impagos trazado en dólares a
un plazo de 5 años escaló hasta los 58 5
puntos desde los 8 puntos 55 registrados
a principios de abril después dejamos
américa latina porque vamos a europa un
importante anuncio del gobierno francés
para ayudar a sudar y es que el
presidente de ese país en manuel macrón
anunció sobre el final de una
conferencia llevada a cabo en parís para
respaldar el proceso de transición en la
nación de su
que anularía la totalidad de la deuda
bilateral y que se acerca a los cinco
mil millones de dólares así mismo el
líder francés instó a otros para que
tomen medidas similares con la finalidad
de liberar a sudán de la carga de deuda
sudán país que en 2008 18 inició una
revolución que derrocó al gobernante
omar al-bashir ostenta una deuda que
asciende según algunos instituciones a
60.000 millones de dólares
adicionalmente parís anunció que
otorgará a sudán unos 1.500 millones de
dólares para saltar la deuda que este
organismo mantiene con el fondo
monetario internacional una iniciativa a
la que se ha sumado también el gobierno
alemán pero escuchemos lo que dijo
emanuel macro puso a 12 - no grupos y
sus así que todos unidos podemos avanzar
hacia el lanzamiento del proceso de
reducción de la deuda
este proceso será formalizado en unas
pocas semanas ante el fm y a finales de
junio de todos tendrían que decir que
esfuerzos pueden hacer sacando a los
diez que él hizo y poca constancia
pues nos desplazamos ahora a eeuu porque
hubo una importante fusión la que
anunciaron el cliente y discovery así es
porque de acuerdo con medios
estadounidenses como business la
combinación de activos de ambas empresas
está orientado al establecimiento de un
conglomerado de medios que aspiran a
competir con servicios como netflix o
títulos el entonces compañía que surge
de esta fusión será propietaria de
canales que incluyen entre otros
ascienden es george tenet y viviese
además de la franquicia warner bros el
acuerdo está estructurado como una
transacción de acciones en el que
exigente y recibirá 40 mil millones de
dólares en efectivo y un alivio de deuda
ya sus accionistas controlarán el 71 por
ciento de la nueva compañía al 29 por
ciento restante quedará en manos de
discovery el acuerdo se produce casi
tres años después de que el cliente
cerró la adquisición del grupo time
warner por 85 mil 400 millones de
dólares y después de toda esta
información vamos con los indicadores de
la jornada en esta ocasión hubo cierres
negativos en el mercado estadounidense
todavía sigue la incertidumbre en todos
a la inflación en europa hubo cierres
mixtos durante la jornada con
crecimiento en la bolsa de milán cayó
nuevamente el mercado japonés en los
índices latinoamericanos comenzaron la
semana con números positivos y
finalizamos con la cifra del día tiene
que ver en este caso con los 989
millones de dólares en pérdidas que
registró la aerolínea ryanair se durante
el año financiero que culminó el pasado
mes de marzo
luisa usted muchas gracias por este
análisis y a ustedes por su sintonía
continúen con nosotros en france 24
[Música]